MAJOR WINNERS.
A LOT OF PLAYERS ON THE PGA TOUR
FEEL THE WAY TIGER WOODS DOES.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO WATCH
THIS WEEK.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>>> IF YOU LIVE IN THE NEW YORK
AREA AND HEARD A LOUD SCREAM
LAST NIGHT, DO NOT BE ALARMED.
IT WAS HARRIET, A CONTESTANT ON
THE BRINK OF VICTORY, MAKE A
MIND-BOGGLING WAGER DURING FINAL
JEOPARDY.
>> THE CATEGORY IS PAIRS IN
ASTRONOMY.
HERE'S THE CLUE.
DISCOVERED IN 1877, THEY WERE
NAMED FOR SIBLINGS OF THE GREEK
GOD OF LOVE.
BEN, WHAT DID YOU WRITE DOWN?
THAT IS CORRECT.
AND HOW MUCH ARE WE GOING TO ADD
TO YOUR SCORE?
$3,000.
THAT GIVES YOU $13,000.
LET'S GO TO OUR RETURNING CHAMP,
STEVE CLARK.
WHAT ARE SAGITTARIUS.
HOW MUCH DID YOU WAGER?
$1.
THAT LEAVES YOU WITH $19,999.
CONGRATULATIONS, YOU ARE OUR
"JEOPARDY!" CHAMPION.
>> OUR SENIOR DATA REPORTER,
HARRY ENTEN IS HERE, AND TO BE
CLEAR, IT WAS THAT MIDDLE BET
AND IT WAS NOT MAKING A WAGER,
WHICH WAS THE ONLY WAY THAT
PERSON COULD HAVE WON.
EXPLAIN.
>> LOOK, WHEN YOU HAVE EXACTLY
HALF AS MUCH AS THE PERSON IN
FIRST PLACE, YOU KNOW THAT
PERSON IN FIRST PLACE IS GOING
TO BET ZERO FOR A TIE BREAKER OR
$1 TO TRY TO GO FOR THE WIN.
IF YOU'RE AT $10,000, YOU MUST
BET EVERYTHING TO GET THE
$20,000 TO HAVE ANY CHANCE OF
WINNING.
SURE ENOUGH, THIS GUY IN SECOND
PLACE ACTUALLY GETS THIS ANSWER
RIGHT.
I COULDN'T BELIEVE IT.
I HAD NO IDEA WHAT THE HECK HE
WAS TALKING ABOUT.
BUT ONLY BY $3,000, THEREBY
GUARANTEEING THAT HE LOSES.
IT WAS LIKE GOING FOR A
TWO-POINTER WITH TWO SECONDS
LEFT IN A BASKETBALL GAME WHEN
YOU NEEDED A THREE-POINTER TO
WIN.
ONE OF THE WORST BETS I HAVE
EVER SEEN.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK HAPPENED?
>> ONE OF TWO THINGS.
NERVES, MAYBE HE JUST GOT
NERVOUS AND DIDN'T KNOW HOW TO
DO THE MATH.
MAYBE HE WAS TRYING TO GUARANTEE
SECOND PLACE.
IF YOU'RE ON "JEOPARDY!" YOU GO
FOR THE WIN.
>> THERE'S NO SECOND PLACE.
>> YOU GET $2,000 IF YOU GET
SECOND PLACE VERSUS $1,000.
THAT MAKES NO SENSE.
I THINK HE SCREWED UP THE MATH.
>> ARE YOU MAD AT HIM OR ARE YOU
MAD WITH HIM?
>> I'M MAD WITH HIM.
>> HOW ARE YOU FEELING?
THERE'S A LOT OF PRESSURE THAT
GOES ON WHEN YOU'RE ON THAT
SHOW.
I'M NOT MAD AT HIM.
BUT IT'S SAD BECAUSE HE HAD THE
CHANCE TO BE A "JEOPARDY!"
CHAMPION, WHICH IS SOMETHING YOU
CAN SAY FOR YOUR LIFETIME AND HE
SCREWED IT UP.
>> TOOK A TWO-POINTER WHEN HE
WAS DOWN BY THREE AT THE END OF
THE